[Musik]
eine dritte major princess und damit
herzlich willkommen meine lieben freunde
zudem mit behinderten spiel was ich je
auf wo gesehen habe oder mir runter
geladen habe es heißt sperma simulator
ich denke der titel verspricht nicht zu
viel das einzige was man machen muss ist
man steuert als protagonisten ein
spermium welches ihr seht schon
eingeblendet die hälfte fertig das heißt
wir müssen das ei befruchten wir müssen
uns in einem der heftigen wettkampf
gegen ein paar andere spermien
durchsetzen wir haben turbo indem wir
nach oben drücken wir können steuer
nehme nach links und rechts drücken mit
den pfeiltasten der download ist in der
beschreibung die webseite könnt euch das
einfach runterladen
dann könnte jetzt auch spielen und ich
habe es bisher nur angespielt und es ist
einfach sogar das ist klasse die
struggle for bird gravity interessieren
für 62 und robin die an ein bisschen
etwas nostalgisches hat auch die ärzte
hatte spiel tieferen sinn
[Musik]
das ist das ganze lied das ist krass
dieses spiel ich sehe auch wieder
richtig müde aus hier weil es auch
gerade neun uhr morgens ist also ihr
seht schon immer ganz die steuerung so
viel ganz normal
dann kann ich den pfeil drücken nach
oben dann bekomme ich so einen schubs
kretschmann damit links und rechts
steuer ich kotzen
watson sogar spermien ist noch einer
vorne die muss sie einholen
[Musik]
das war die princess of the game
keine ahnung sagt wir können jetzt hier
das war s das war das spiel beim ohv
aurich wer nicht ich wenn ich das ganze
nicht normal spielen würde meine damen
und herren
von daher würde ich sagen
[Musik]
turtle major brillen setzt man jetzt mal
einfach hier super saltos und damit wir
mal sehen was passiert wenn mir dein
letzter sind doch ein bisschen frech
dass wir den hut aufhaben kommen den den
kollegen hier lassen auch mal vorstellen
dass ich die ganze zeit dreht ja ja das
sieht so krank aus wenn man überlegt
dass die befruchtung prozent wenn er
wirklich so wäre hätte bis 19 ich mir
als frau oder sowas darum schwimmt aber
sind für musik haben muss man sagen aber
ich glaube wenn ihr nicht schwer wir
damals so gegen die wände mal geflogen
wäre ich echt ein bisschen doof im kopf
bin ich ja stark spielt trotzdem jetzt
gewonnen ich bin einfach durch das ding
durch durch die befruchtete eizelle ja
freunde ich würde sagen dass war der
spurs you later
das ist jetzt nicht so ein großes spiel
gewählt wo ich bin auch total hell weil
hier wieder die ganzen sonne und ich
habe nicht mal irgendeine softbox an
oder so kennt euch solche kleinen
abgepackten sachen gefallen also heute
kommt ja noch ein zweites video der
braucht er keine sorgen machen weil das
hier ist ein kurzes für zwischendurch
weil ich fand's einfach echt so witzig
also wenn euch so etwas gefällt wo ich
dann so ein kleines dritte teil des
videos aus zusammenstellen soll das
gameplay den sommer haben bisschen
anderen spielen vielleicht doch mal mit
happy meals oder irgendwas oder mit
ihren spielerinnen kommt da wird dann
schreibt sie mir die kommentare lasse es
nicht durch eine bewertung wissen wir
können dir selber spielen
[Musik]